[Music]
did you get any happier when you got
rich
what do you think a healthy view of
money is so i'll i'll take this as a as
an opportunity to give a shameless plug
to
a friend of mine actually ramit seti
and
s-e-t-h-i and his podcast which i think
is just i will teach you to be rich it
may have a different name but if you
just find ramit sethi and his podcast
each episode and i've listened to a ton
of them he has generally a couple on and
they talk about their money
issues their money priorities what it
means to live a rich life and what you
realize very quickly is that
people have neuroses
or stories at the very least around
money
that
both help and hurt them no matter how
much money they have so he can talk to a
couple where
they barely have enough money to scrape
by and they're hundreds of thousands of
dollars in debt or he can talk to a
couple that's worth 10 million dollars
and is still comparison shopping for
strawberries
and
at the very least it normalizes some of
the unanswered questions and maybe
unrealistic expectations that people
have around
money to answer your question directly
i would say that
it's hard for me first of all to point
to a line after which
i felt
rich if that makes any sense whatsoever
and
that
if for the time being and i'm borrowing
this from someone else i think it was a
podcast guess but the value or cost of
something being the amount of life
energy you exchange for it
so you give to it or get from it right
in the in the
sort of pro and con
positive and negative sides of things
and
what i've noticed for a lot of my
friends is that past a certain point
wealth actually turns into a
energy consuming
facet of their lives and this is not to
complain uh because certainly i feel and
i am extremely fortunate for a million
reasons
but i have observed people who while
they are on the hunt while they are on
the journey to become rich and i'm
putting that in quotation marks in my
mind because i think the goal posts tend
to move for people
and it is and can be a very nebulous
goal but implicit in that is very often
the assumption that once i have this
money once i am rich once i have won
that game
most of my problems
or many of my problems will be solved
and
on maslow's hierarchy if we're talking
about shelter food
right so rent or mortgage etc that type
of thing it can be true
but the psychological psycho-emotional
issues
tend to not just not get fixed but
sometimes get exaggerated so
by that i mean power alcohol money tend
to magnify whatever is there it's also
true with psychedelics for a lot of
people
and
if you have say paranoia or you're
worried about people ripping you off
fill in the blank it could be any number
of things if
you feel insecure in ways a b and c
all of those levers i just mentioned
including money
tend to amplify those things if
someone's generous they're gonna be
super generous if someone's a stingy
[ __ ] they're gonna be a super stingy
[ __ ]
and so on and so forth
and
what i found is that people can be very
happy and often are very upbeat
when they can hold in their mind the
belief
that
once they cross the finish line these
problems will be fixed once they have
the money
more often than not they realize that's
not the case and it can actually
result in
different types of and maybe more
intractable types of depression or
malaise because then it's like well wait
a second for 20 years 30 years i've
assumed this would solve the problem it
didn't now what
and
on top of that i would say once you have
team once you have more stuff let's say
somebody buys a second house
etc all of that consumes life energy on
some level and you can create systems
and so on but it does create
a bandwidth drain
and for instance if you have a bunch of
money
people are going to ask you for that
money constantly in some form or another
and you will feel compelled
most people will to think about
investing a lot and
generating that initial wealth and being
really good at investing are two
entirely different sports
so you may be very well suited to the
former and very ill suited to the latter
so again coming back to your direct
question did i get any happier when i
got rich i would say that having a
certain degree of relief especially when
thinking about caring for
aging parents when thinking about
being able to help family members
being able to help
family members and close friends during
something like covid for instance
especially in the beginning when there
was a lot of uncertainty and having some
capital made a difference in terms of
having optionality and moving people
around and so on
all of those things i would say give me
a greater peace of mind
and a certain degree of
stillness but
on the other side of the ledger there's
a lot of [ __ ] that eats energy what do i
think a healthy view of money is
i would suggest that you actually
listen to
my podcast episode with morgan housel
h-o-u-s-e-l
on the psychology of money this was a
hugely popular episode and i thought it
would be reasonably popular but it ended
up getting a lot of spread via word of
mouth and becoming mega popular so i'd
suggest listening to that i would also
say i don't have all the answers because
i fit in the category of someone who
thought money would fix tons and tons
and tons of things and be able to
exhale and go maybe lay on a beach and
rub cocoa butter on my belly and read
novels and
be perfectly content to do that for
months and months of the year turns out
not to be the case also if you're
accustomed to driving in sixth gear
on the autobahn and you've done that for
20 30 years getting used to like driving
through a school district and stopping
at red lights and so on at 20 miles an
hour
is not automatically easy to do you you
think it would be but if you're used to
park or mostly sixth gear getting used
to the gears in between
at least for me personally has been very
challenging so
i'm still working on it and i think this
is a fascinating fascinating question so
i may not have given much clarity
but
that is my my current state of play with
these questions
you